[Music]
I only had 37 seconds I wrote this 43
years ago okay okay can I just say skip
Brittenham said to me a long time ago if
you stay at the table long enough the
chips come to you and tonight I got to
clear the table
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how are you digesting this moment I
don't know how anybody digests all of
this that quickly I'm completely
overwhelmed and and really grateful this
is crazy I watched Alex and win and Amy
win yeah yeah the dolphin I didn't know
coming and this is absolutely insane
did you think in your wildest dreams you
can emmy-winner
no no it's bananas okay so they call
your name and what goes through your
mind I like very yelled a giant
expletive right into my ear and then I
turned around and went oh gosh and then
some something in my brain said you need
to stand up and so I stood up and I went
up there and then I hey I hugged the guy
from Atlanta and then and then the I
think I went up
[Music]
I'd also finally like to thank my horse
Apollo he he was Jeff Bridges horse on
True Grit and I felt he was making
unfair comparisons
congratulations to Regina King for
winning I just want to remind everybody
that Jeff Daniels thanked his horse
you guys are witnessing the most
extraordinary moment of my life thus far
so this is pretty cool
thank you Dave and Dan you are honestly
the most talented amazing people I know
besides my wife Erica who I think I
forgot to thank a couple years ago so
thank you Erica for putting up with me
I'm very temperamental I love you very
much I know I was so complete I know but
this is fabulous that's the best way
think I'd be a little bit prepared but
no
[Music]
congratulations
yes I feel like mahogany in the Kabuki
finale you know
[Music]
you walk out of here with a bunch of
Emmys and how good does it feel it feels
nice because we can hurt people if they
come and try and take uppers I don't
know but I think near my bed in case of
home invasion
let's show as only as good as the people
who make it and we are blessed and lucky
to have the greatest cast the greatest
crew led by and the greatest team of
producers led by the inimitable Bernie
Caulfield